Speaker 1: Donald Trump started posting
uncontrollably to truth social after we learned
last night that he has been indicted federally and
will have to appear in Miami on Tuesday. First and
foremost, if you just sort of like scroll through
Trump's Truth social. Every few minutes there's a
post. It's either a meme or a video or people
praying with Trump or Republicans supporting
Trump. And you can scroll, scroll, scroll, like,
we're just scrolling here endlessly and there is
just no shortage of this stuff. Truth social.
Apparently having some glitches, but Trump
spending hours and hours and hours posting this
stuff. One of the first things he did last night
upon the indictment was post a video, which we
will look at in a moment. But just before that, he
posted a three troth rant, which reads as follows
The corrupt Biden administration has informed my
attorneys that I have been indicted with a capital
I seemingly over the boxes hoax. Even though Joe
Biden has 850 boxes at the University of
Delaware, additional boxes in Chinatown,
D.C., with even more boxes at the University of
Pennsylvania and documents strewn all over his
garage floor where he parks his Corvette, which
is secured by only a garage door that is paper
thin and open much of the time. This is a former
president. Ladies and gentlemen, page two. I have
been summoned to appear at the federal courthouse
in Miami on Tuesday at 3 p.m.. I never thought it
possible that such a thing could happen to
a former president of the United States who
received far more votes than any sitting president
in the capital H history of our Capital C country
and is currently leading by far all Capital
C candidates, both Democrat and Republican in
Capital P polls of the 2024 presidential election.
I am an innocent man. And lastly, on page three,
this is indeed a dark day for the United States
of America. We are a country in serious and rapid
decline, but together we will make America great
again. Now we're going to look at the video.
But the most important point about all of this
that I can make to you, and that is important
not to lose sight of as we are going to see the
firehose of propaganda really get ramped up over
the next few weeks and days and months. There are
those on the right who want you to believe that
because Donald Trump is being indicted, the system
is broken. They point to the Trump indictment and
say, See, this is the problem with the country.
Our institutions aren't trustworthy. We are
a nation in decline. This is all bad. And they
couldn't be more wrong. The indictments of Trump
prove that, at least at this point in the process,
no one is above the law they love. To say if they
can do it to Trump, they could do it to anybody.
We knew that they could do it to anybody. And we
know that when we say there's a two tiered justice
system, we talk about the wealthy and elite with
access to the best lawyers and unlimited money
for defenses and everybody else. We knew about
the two tiered justice system. They want to tell
you the two tiered justice system is left wingers
and right wingers. There is no evidence of that.
And what we have to accept, if we honestly assess
the situation, is that Trump's indictments tell us
no one is above the law. That's a good thing. Now,
whether he will get special treatment in later
phases of this remains to be seen. Here's
Trump's video that he put out. It's very stupid.
Speaker 2: Very sadly, we're a nation in decline.
And yet they go after a popular president,
a president that got more votes than any
sitting president in the history of our country.
Speaker 1: Irrelevant to whether one committed
a crime, of course.
Speaker 2: By far
and in much better the second time in the election
and the first irrelevant. And they go after him
on a boxer's hoax, just like the Russia, Russia,
Russia hoax and all of the others. This has been
going on for seven years. They can't stop because
it's election interference at the highest level.
There's never been anything like what's happened.
I'm an innocent man. I'm an innocent person. They
had the Mueller hoax, the Mueller report, and that
came out. No collusion after two and a half years.
Speaker 1: Well, I'm convinced.
Speaker 2: That was set up by
Hillary Clinton and Democrats. But
this is what they do. This is what they
do so well, if they would devote their
energies to honesty and integrity,
we'll be a lot better for our country.
Speaker 1: All right. So it's basically
the typical grievances from Trump. After a
three trust, trust after a three troth screed
on truth central. So Trump losing it. But this
is nothing compared to Fox News host Mark Levin